hey andy hi conan how are you well i'm
pretty good sometimes i get a little
upset that our country seems so divided
but then i
i'm inspired by our audience because our
audience here is united
in that they're all made of
look at that no diverging opinions here
finally the audience i always wanted
forced to look at me
right forced to look at me in stony
silence
yes no i think this is pretty much
probably
not many cardboard cutouts here think
that the election was fraudulent i think
for the most part
uh the cardboard cutouts in our audience
believe in the integrity of the election
yes
they're institutionalists for sure yeah
not sure about that
cat you know i wanted to talk about this
after this
presidential election let's face it our
country as i just said remains as
divided as ever
a few days ago the gap that's right the
gap
thought the solution was to post this
tweet check it out
a photo of a half red half blue
sweatshirt
and quote the one thing we know is that
together we can move forward
well unsurprisingly there was immediate
backlash
and the gap took that down but
the bad press it's a little unfair
because the gap wasn't the only company
trying to heal the nation with their
tweets
yeah general mills tweeted a photo of
count chocula's cereal with
count every vote and every bite of
chocolatey goodness
smuckers tweeted when peanut butter and
jelly come together
it leads to swirled peace hashtag
yomocracy fancy feast tweeted
whether you're a demo cat or a
republican
one thing's for sure you'll love the
taste of real liver pate
charleston chute tweeted charleston
muslim charleston jew
hashtag we are all americans hashtag
move forward
heal nougat arby's tweeted
is our meat red or blue trick question
it's purple
and so is our country this hospital
tweeted
if your baby turns red or blue humana
children's hospital is there for you
oh my god oh my god
oh my god hey i'm just reporting the
news
mattel tweeted barbie's a racist karen
from orange county
ken is a left of bernie socialist cuck
if they can make it work
so can we and finally main entail horse
shampoo for people tweeted
we know these are precarious times but
ah forget it
what the [ __ ] do we know we made horse
shampoo for people
[Laughter]
yeah so i don't know why everyone just
got mad at the gap everyone's in on this
yeah yeah every company is wrong about
something
you bet especially that horse and tail
shampoo